bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de
revue de lecture Wolf Bonjour
[Musique]
elle est pas en grande forme
politiquement et pourtant on va parler
de la gauche et d'une figure tutélaire
de la gauche qui est avec Frédéric
potier
[Musique]
vous êtes délégué à l'éthique et à la
conformité à la RATP
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
toutes les questions de laïcité de
neutralité religieuse de
programme en faveur de la par exemple
dans une entreprise
[Musique]
et inversement proportionnel
les caractéristiques il y avait des
petites accord avec volume
oui alors ils sont pas exactement issus
de la même famille politique parce que
Léon Blum et socialisme marxiste il
était très pris par l'idéologie de son
temps alors que Mendès France lui est
plutôt un homme du 20e siècle a beaucoup
d'ouvrages de droite sur sociale à Lucas
ils sont en anglais d'ailleurs avant
tout le monde et donc c'est pas
et
[Musique]
il appartient
nationale
et puis il est plusieurs fois ministre
sous la 4e République et surtout il est
président du Conseil la
période pendant 7 mois et 18 jours
exactement
entre le 18 juin 54 le 5 février 55 mois
qui compte énormément
dans la politique parce que c'est la fin
de la guerre d'Indochine
dans la stature et
moi
parce qu'en fait il arrive
pour moi je suis prêt à
discuter avec
fait il l'assume ça et au-delà de de
cette question de de la peine qu'il
arriva arriva il arriva avec d'autres
formes début de la décolonisation c'est
l'homme qui va à Tunis pour dire qu'il
faut avoir un propre hein parce que
c'est pas le début de la décolonisation
mais il parle de l'autonomie interne
donc il amorce une politique et puis sur
le plan économique aussi beaucoup de
choses pour moderniser pays est donc ce
qui Mendès France se forge en 1954 et
après toute la pensée de gauche de bien
au-delà de la gauche tout ce qui se
reconnaissent quand des idéaux
démocratique
et
[Musique]
aujourd'hui
moi 18 jours donc il est quand même
victime de cette 4e République
de l'instabilité ministère de la 4e
République et pourtant il va toujours se
poser aux institutions de la 5e parce
qu'il considère que la 5e République et
néo dans coup d'État
et par conséquent il va refuser même de
participer aux institutions de la Vème
République ne sera jamais candidat à la
présidence bien qu'on lui demander il
sera juste en 69 comme promis mise de
garçon de faire ce qu'il veut comme
ça il faut le reconnaître a beaucoup de
cohérence constance dans ces idées dans
sa pratique du pouvoir il refuse la 5e
République parce qu'ils
ne sont pas démocratique
contre le
suffrage universel direct
et
[Musique]
Classic un grand fan de Turquie le
modèle allemand aussi et voilà donc il a
des institutions il essaye quand même de
participer à la vie intellectuelle et
politique du pays où il s'engage avec
Gaston Defferre donc il faut un ticket
complet parce que on est après 68 et
puis les événements mais ce qui est
vraiment c'est qui ne cesse tout au long
de cette période-là et en dépit des
échecs de penser la démocratie et de
croire profondément dans la délibération
collective et un c'est vraiment un modem
question parce que
c'est
là c'est la moelle si cette grande
statue du Commandeur qui ferait que la
politique ne peut être que machiavélique
est la vérité serai à l'échec et moi
j'essaie de te rendre le coup à cette
idée-là en montrant que ma Mendès France
il est très évident et il parle et puis
après il fait des choix tactique et
stratégie qui sont pas bons ou quoi il
s'isole un peu
le leadership sur la gauche et c'est
Mitterrand après qui qui
arrive mais je voudrais pas faire croire
que les chèques de demander sur le plan
politique
forcément la vérité l'honnêteté et
l'éthique en politique
gauche ensuite ils se sont revendiquer
de Pierre Mendès France on peut penser
que c'est en quelque sorte un peu le
père de Michel Rocard
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on peut utiliser ce terme
social-démocrate du même d'ailleurs a
après la Seconde Guerre mondiale se pose
l'action de créer un nouveau parti un
grand parti travailliste comme commande
en Grande-Bretagne ou en Allemagne et en
fait il fait pas chaud là il reste au
Parti radical parce que en attachement
aux idéaux de la Révolution aux idéaux
finalement de gens comme Clemenceau
comme Jules Ferry et donc il
n'entre pas il ne crée pas parti
social-démocrate mais tout ça pratique
et toute la France et il part tout ça et
ça et qu'il y a beaucoup avec des
premiers ministres suédois avec des prix
Nobel d'économie et en fait Mendès
France a un peu le passeur de cette
gauche humaniste républicaine du 19e
siècle à clefs grand monde que
j'évoquais avec Clemenceau et il fait le
témoin le passeur vers cette deuxième
gauche qui rit de la deuxième moitié du
20e siècle dans laquelle on grossit
retrouver des gens comme Jacques Delors
Badinter Gaston Defferre qu'on a cité et
donc là aussi encore un personnage très
singulier et
qui arrive finalement on a passé des
idées il ne cesse d'ailleurs d'insister
là-dessus je cours à la Genèse
informations sur la nécessité de
réformer intellectuellement
et
lance-moi ancien président du Conseil
Mendès France
voilà après les témoignages historique
que le préfet de police
et
émission qui qui font en larme devant
François Mitterrand qui ont le
droit qu'il faut comprendre cette scène
comme finalement une forme de
complémentarité aussi tu es une adulte
et tac tic
machiavélique florentine chez François
Mitterrand
peut-être le fait d'avoir pris
conscience que lui-même aller aussi
contribué à crédit viser la gauche
c'est-à-dire que le fait que en 80 la
gauche devient majoritaire c'est aussi
parce que elle allait faire un bout de
chemin et que il y avait une forme de
crédibilité sur les questions
économiques institutionnels et et je
pense qu'il était il était venu aussi
que Mitterrand lui dise que sans lui
rien n'aurait été possible après ce que
ça vaut rien il écrit d'ailleurs il y a
un petit mot manuscrit
[Musique]
refuser
pas du tout il a concentrer sur sa
personne un certain nombre de de préjugé
de stéréotype antisémite très puissant
depuis les années 30 où il est lui en
Normandie
dans une circonscription en partie du
hall jusqu'à la fin de sa vie il reçoit
encore des des insulter et cette
heure-ci mais c'est ça aussi c'est très
actuels
c'est un combat Mendès France ne
dissocie pas des valeurs de la
République de l'État de droit la
Déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen et donc il combat
l'antisémitisme non pas au nom d'une
forme de communautarisme mes vidéos qui
était très profondément ancré chez lui
et ça je trouve ça très très actuels et
je crois qu'on en a vraiment besoin
d'abord 50 ans
contre casse
la figure
une toute petite partie une toute petite
synthèse des 50 années de réflexion de
Pierre Mendès France avec des oeuvres
complètes qui font 6 x 800 pages et donc
moi c'est ça que j'ai voulu donner à
voir avec ce livre c'est qu'est-ce qui
reste demander sens pour répondre à
votre question c'est si une forme de
netteté de droiture et bien sûr mais il
forme de réflexion très très très
puissante sur la politique étrangère
chez Mendès France elle doit être
transparente démocratique sous contrôle
du Parlement là on a une politique
étrangère française vos dispo tradition
très théâtral avec des grands gestes
exetera ça y est reçu ça il y a des
réflexions sur l'Europe qui sont
passionnantes Mendès France vote contre
le traité de Rome en 57 qui vend le
point de départ
[Musique]
et
et donc il y a le gars il y a beaucoup
de réflexion sur l'Europe qui sont
encore d'une très très très grande
actualités et puis sur l'économie voilà
il propose
européen mais je crois de voir que tel
que l'Europe se construit à l'époque
elle ne cause pas toutes les cases ont
trouvé un associe pas suffisamment de
citoyens qui crée des questions de de
légitimité et d'adhésion et
ça va très mal d'accord mais mais vous
faites quoi
le message c'est beaucoup ça aussi c'est
une interpellation des gouvernants mais
aussi des gouvernés chaque citoyen a
quelque chose à donner à on doit tous
contribué à cette démocratie que lui il
veut généraliser permanente et au fond
si ça va pas bien démocratie on en a
tous une petite part de responsabilité
de la mairie
avant que les femmes ont eu le droit de
vote
spécial exetera
il a pris la gauche parce que à cause de
ce réalisme économique or c'est
lui qui
est
comme ça
franc-maçon donc ça fait beaucoup quand
même pour voilà et puis
internat la Tunisie mais aussi il
réussit une décoloration oublié
d'ailleurs c'est les comptoir comptoir
des Indes Pondichéry et cetera et réussi
cette négociation avec avec l'Inde pour
avoir une décolonisation qui se passe
très bien
qu'on a encore beaucoup de viande à
l'heure avec la Fédération indienne
alors ça
c'est une publication publication
et
tout à l'heure
inquiétant puisque vous vous montrer que
tu sais discours de haine c'est de se
déverser à outrance en ligne la
proposition de loi qui a été censuré par
le Conseil constitutionnel alors comment
est-ce qu'on fait pour
lutter contre en ligne et aussi il se
croit que c'est important comment on
fait pour ne pas donner au four et
laisser aller temps la conservation de
la définition des contours de la lumière
de la salle à manger aujourd'hui il y a
un clip le combat quand il y a un combat
intellectuel donc ça ça passe par la
réalisation de certaines figure dont ton
parle ça parle
aussi des travaux de formation donc ça
se combat moral politique
de terrain citoyen moi je salue vraiment
des associations je pense qu'elles ont
pas assez de moyens considérables
sensibilisation
pour appeler
et puis
alors vous disais que la loi radia
effectivement avec ah oui oui elle a été
censuré par conséquent
comment réguler la haine sur internet
comment réduire les contenus comment
protège la liberté d'expression mais
comment on fait en sorte aussi que une
vidéo et qui appelle à la violence
exetera ne reste pas en ligne plus de 24
heures ou midi ou 72 heures c'est ça le
sujet on a une note
pour dire
c'est
aujourd'hui
qu'on devrait avoir
les circuler de manière massive beaucoup
de contenus dangereux et qui fragilise
la démocratie et ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui à un peu banal dans le Jura
ensemble mais c'est un peu ça quand même
[Musique]
tu es complètement indépendante avec les
Danois qu'on donne pas
on débouche sur une question de
politique
qui pourquoi comment je pense que
au-delà du filtre de la justice qui a un
filtre les gars il y a aussi la question
est-ce que
je
pense que
abrasif
mais à la fin c'est la démocratie et
puis c'est français qui tranche
justement parce qu'on a
un sondage qui vient de paraître dance
challenge
il faut sauver la démocratie avec ce
chiffre 61 pourcents des Français estime
en danger un système vocale sont en très
grande majorité attaché donc il y a bien
dit tout à l'heure cette part de nos
concitoyens qui est très attaché à cette
fois démocratique
de cette fois démocratique et en même
temps on va dire les critiques sont très
fort
alors
c'est une fois tous les cinq en mettant
ses l'État de droit c'est la liberté
d'expression c'est la possibilité
d'avoir collectivement un débat apaisé
et donc que des Français considère que
tous ces éléments la soie manger moi je
partage plus tôt ce con ça là on n'est
pas simplement sur est-ce que j'aurai
droit de voter pas demain la question
c'est est-ce que collectivement on
arrive à débattre et est-ce que
lorsqu'elle est décision petit qui sont
pris des décisions judiciaires qui sont
en est-ce que tout ça est
légitime et accepter il me permets
encore une fois de pouvoir faire société
ensemble je pense que c'est ça
Ouais je pense que c'est
exigeant